hey everybody welcome to rollback
rollback is my way of introducing
powerful enlightening and evergreen
conversations from the prehistoric
pre-video days of the podcast right here
on youtube for the very first time
conversations like this one from july of
2015
with former nfl star david carter aka
the 300 pound vegan
like most athletes david grew up eating
tons of meat fully adhering to the
conventional mythology that in order to
become muscle you must consume muscle
but as his career matured david became
plagued by a variety of persistent
chronic injuries including arthritis and
tendonitis ailments he simply could not
overcome that left him sidelined despite
the best sports medicine and
rehabilitative resources of the nfl at
his disposal and so through a series of
rather improbable events in february of
2014
david made this rather radical and quite
controversial decision which was to
adopt a 100
plant-based diet
as a result
to the great surprise of his coaches his
trainers his teammates
every single one of those nagging
persistent injuries mysteriously
corrected themselves and ultimately
vanished altogether all his numbers in
the weight room went up he found himself
quicker more agile and more responsive
than ever
and perhaps most important to david
no living thing had to die in order for
him to thrive
it's a truly special exchange with an
exceptional human being that explores a
typical day in the life of the nfl
it's a peak into the typical nfl diet
what he eats now on a daily basis and
tons more i sincerely hope you enjoy our
discussion and look forward to your
thoughts
in the comments section below
so are you writing a book right now
we're getting ready to start writing a
cookbook
yeah because we're
we're working with lighter and all that
stuff so we'll talk about it later yeah
we could talk about it now no i was like
oh don't want to use all the questions
no it's cool we're already rolling man
[Laughter]
okay we could edit it out if you want to
but uh that's fine yeah man that's
exciting at cookbook huh yeah we're you
know a lot of people are asking a lot of
questions like you know what are you
eating
where can i get my protein from how the
hell are you getting 10 000 calories in
a day or i eat like
well i eat like 300 plus grams of
protein a day they're like how are you
getting that on a vegan diet so
it only makes sense to put um yeah of
course cookbook out there well uh i
don't know if you guys know but we just
had a cookbook that just came out yeah
i'll give you guys a copy of it
don't let me forget yeah because i'm
gonna run out and get one i got one with
your name on it right cool man well uh
thanks for uh making the time to come on
over here and do this thanks man i
appreciate you having me on this show it
means a lot oh cool well i've been
following uh your journey from afar
for a while and
it's quite an inspiring story it's a
unique story and i think it's a it's an
important story i mean there's a lot of
similarities in our journey and and you
know some distinct
differences as well and i kind of want
to get into all of it man but uh
i think the best way to just kick it off
is like let's just go back to the
beginning dude like where does where
does football start with you where'd you
grow up like how did you kind of
uh you know blaze this path into
becoming a college football player and
beyond into the nfl oh okay well uh i'm
taking it way back yeah that's way back
well let's set the stage all right
well um well i have a brother and we
both play football um
so we started in high school we started
in pop warner like five you go out you
grew up out here yeah i grew up in los
angeles should have said that in los
angeles native
grew up in southern los angeles uh my
brother and sister and my two parents
and uh
so my brother and i started playing pop
warner football at crenshaw
high school his uh pop warner team and
we were you know defensive lineman there
and then on to high school and you know
the basics
college i went to ucla uh did you have a
good high school football team yeah we
got to we won we were pretty good we
went uh we won the
it was a long time ago hard for me to
remember
oh come on man what are you 26 27 27
you're literally half my age almost yeah
i know right all right come on but uh
we were with the kaiser high school we
had a pretty good football team my
brother and i we were known as the
bookends i played one league the left
defensive end the strong side defensive
end my brother played the right side
defensive end and we went to win on a
lot of games we were like 10 and 12.
so that's pretty good we didn't win the
championship but that's pretty damn good
you know and what's it what's he doing
now who's in the nfl oh he is yeah i
didn't know that
wow who's he played with right now he's
a free agent i think so
you know with your brother
because he just got signed
but unless he just got signed but uh
yeah he went on he played with the
steelers for two years with the colts
one year at the bengals another year so
we both actually got drafted at the same
time i didn't know that wow yeah we were
both playing both defensive linemen yeah
he was a defensive end i was a defen
interior defensive lineman
and we actually got drafted on the same
day we're the first brothers to get
drafted on the same day in the nfl
that's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
awesome so hold on he's wait he's older
or he's younger he's younger than me
younger but in college you red shirt i
had a redshirt year because i wasn't big
enough i was like 250 to 60
in college my freshman year
so uh they were like oh yeah you got a
red shirt and a red shirt a year and
then yeah but he didn't have to red
shirt because he was
playing a smaller position like an
outside linebacker defensive end
position did he go to ucla also no he
went to fresno state
so he did pretty well that's pretty
special man so uh i mean are your
parents still around yeah yeah that must
have been a big moment for them both
their both their sons getting drafted on
the same day it's amazing yeah they're
pretty excited and they're a couple
people passed out and draft party like
oh my gosh
they both got drafted at the same time
oh geez that's amazing yeah so all right
so uh
so you're playing at ucla
and
i mean did you have a sense that uh you
know you were headed for the for the big
show i mean was that i mean obviously
that's you know your dream right i mean
was it looking like it was gonna work
out or how did how does that all play
out uh you know i didn't i didn't know
if i was gonna get drafted to the league
but i did pretty well my senior year
junior senior year and ended up going in
the uh fifth round mm-hmm
sixth round
she keeps the stats yeah the sixth round
my brother went fifth round and i went
sixth round and but um yeah and i ended
up doing well after
uh college you know played defensive end
and interior tackle when i got to the
league i got drafted sixth round they
were like oh he's not you know six round
draft they didn't think i was going to
last too long but i ended up starting my
uh my rookie year oh you did at the
cardinals at the arizona cardinals that
nose tackle and i was undersized
most defensive nose tackles are like 340
pounds and i was 300 starting at the
what do you what do you attribute that
to i mean did you have some kind of
extra speed or agility yeah that was
quick i'm very quick for my size i
wasn't vegan then nothing yeah right now
we're getting it don't worry but uh very
quick for my size and i did and very
strong and i did very well and made a
lot of plays a lot of stats uh-huh so
yeah my first sack was uh was manning
and the giants wow it's so yeah that's
pretty good how many games in was that
i don't remember what game that was
paige might know your page do you
remember
how long you guys been together oh wow
since before it's like sophomore year of
college oh nice yeah called sweethearts
yeah so it's been a long time yeah and
you've been kind of a journeyman in the
nfl i mean you played for a bunch of
teams you played for the cardinals and
then the cowboys and then the raiders
and then the jaguars right so you have a
pretty good sense
for how the nfl functions for how these
various teams operate and you know kind
of
um you know what the nfl is all about
and i'm interested as somebody who you
know
you know i watch football i don't watch
a ton of football but you know i just
see it on television i don't know that
many guys that that play in the nfl
uh and i think it would be
you know i'd love to know a little bit
about you know what what a real like
day in the life of an nfl player is
because i think we have this
um perhaps
uh you know kind of hyper
uh
perhaps exaggerated sense of like how
sexy it is and it's just sort of like
all fly and you're all up in the club
and throwing money around and
everybody's living in a huge mansion and
driving a ferrari you know what i mean i
think that's like sort of a conventional
idea of the typical football player i
mean but what is it really like
well it is you're right it is kind of
sexy but uh it is it's hard work at the
same time you know you're
you're you're working all day working
out all day like you said a lot of
people sit behind the desk all day and
work you're working out all day every
day you wake up at
you know your workouts started like five
o'clock in the morning and then you have
like four hours of meetings and watching
film and studying your opponent
and learning plays and the playbooks are
the playbooks are thicker than like
calculus textbooks and they're huge and
you have to remember all those plays
otherwise you're not playing and so
it's very uh
it's
it is a lot of hard work and then not to
mention the the beating that you're
taking all day when you're working when
you're working out i'm talking about
working out talking about practices and
practices or practices are hard they're
tedious and a lot of stress on the body
you're going up say for example my
position the defensive line
you're going up against two other guys
that are your size or bigger
and uh you know you're doing that all
day every day and then after that you
have to rehab and you know how that goes
after after so you're you're trying to
you know reset bones that have been like
knocked out of place you have to go to a
chiropractor or you have to stretch out
muscles that have been sprained or
they're bruised and you got it's a lot
of hard work yeah yeah i think you said
in one of your posts or somewhere on
your website that
every day of practice is like being in a
60 mile an hour car crash yeah man
that's uh that's definitely true and you
feel it and you feel it in your joints
and
all that stuff a lot of guys end up
having like tendonitis and all that just
from the constant banging
and uh yeah you're never it's it's never
like you wake up and feel good right
there's always something
that's off or a pain or a little niggle
or an injury
at the very minimum right at the very
minimum a lot of guys get really good at
uh kind of just like phasing like tuning
it out of their mind like uh it's not
pain it's you know what's what's really
pain are you bleeding right can you walk
and you're not hurt you just sore but
really you have a slipped disc or
something like that
and uh
and i would imagine along with that you
know there's all the pressure of like
trying to hold on to your job right like
so you're not gonna
necessarily be forthright about
something that's bugging you yeah i mean
you don't want to create the perception
that
you know you're injured no definitely
not because the team will use that
against you if you're if you're injured
or something like that uh
like for example this is a perfect
example the team doctors
you know you you go to doctor to get
help you know have them look at you and
tell you know what's wrong and how to
fix it
but the doctors don't work for you
there's no like privilege right they go
right to the coach yeah the doctors work
for the team
so if you tell them you know if
something's wrong with you they're not
going to help people like all right man
don't worry about it you'll get back out
you're going you're going to be good
like no they're going to tell the
coaches
and then
he's on he's on the out yeah get him out
of there and and that's how that works
so yeah you know like
you gotta you gotta it's a it's very
political it's a game it's a chess game
and you have to know how to play it
definitely what are some of the
political mistakes that maybe you made
early on that you learned from
and kind of navigating you know how the
teams function and how you relate to the
coach
hmm political mistakes i don't know
about political mistakes but or just
maybe things you witnessed or
political mistakes this or not mistakes
yeah political things uh for example
uh guys who get the big contracts
they can do no wrong
so
uh i've seen a guy
uh
like
i don't know i don't know guy spitting
another guy's face or something like
that or
try to knock another guy who's
who got so much money you know the guy
who's got all the money try to knock
another guy off of it off you know hurt
them
the coach sees it they can't they don't
do anything about it because you know
the guys that you invested in that guy
yeah to invest in that guy so and that's
you know it's an investment that's their
they pay that guy 100 million dollars
they're not going to get rid of him
they're going to get rid of the guy who
is you know
who's trying to come up and take that
guy's job they'll trade him that's
another thing if someone's doing really
well they pay the guy 100 million
dollars they're not going to get rid of
the guy who's got 100 million dollars
they're going to get rid of that guy the
guy was up and coming
right and after playing under you know a
variety of different nfl coaches what
would you how would you characterize
you know the better coaches like what is
it that the better coaches are doing
that the other coaches aren't like how
would you qualify
you know a great coach from an average
coach
a great coach
allows
the players to to play you know if
someone the best person is going to play
yeah
on any team you're going to have that
where you know the guy who's got the 100
million dollar contract is going to play
but
the good coaches find a place for
someone to play and they they they keep
it simple for the players to to do what
they got to do because when you're out
there flying around at 100 miles an hour
you know you're not trying to think
you're just trying to act and you're
trying to make moves to make things
happen
and uh the coaches realize what's going
on they understand the dynamic of the
team
they know how to uh
that's one that's a really important
thing they know how to to keep a team a
team you know it starts you have to make
it like a family first a friendship a
lot of coaches like to make it so
competitive that there's so much tension
in the locker room and on the field uh
trying to compete for positions that you
know guys are just stressed out and you
can't you can't operate underneath it
undermines the bigger goal which is the
team winning right definitely yeah i had
uh
this guy michael gervais on the podcast
he's a sports psychologist who works
with pete carroll and the seahawks and
he was talking about like pete brought
him on to help create you know a
positive team-oriented environment and
also to
instill practices of mindfulness and
visualization and meditation which i
know are things that that you practice
and are into um but maybe our uh you
know slightly off-kilter for the average
football player and it was really
interesting talking to him because he
you know he talked about how
you know basically his goal was to
create an environment where each player
could could bring out the best in them
right so it's about overcoming that kind
of
inherent competitiveness where
everybody's worried about their job to
create kind of you know a unity around
the larger goal exactly they've been
really successful with that right right
take that recipe and like repeat that
you know i like i like pete man he like
you said he's he's very you're not
supposed to say that as a ucla guy i
know man but
i know i get i just i thought about that
before i said no one's listening i have
to say it
but hey he won he wins games and like
you said he's the sc coach oh that's it
coach he beat us when i when i was at
ucla but
he wins games and every single player
that i've met and i know that played
under him they love that guy and uh
you know he he makes it he sets an
environment where it's where people can
want to come to work every day and they
want to come work out and they want to
play their hardest and put their neck on
the line for him and
you know that's how you win games and
you don't have to create like a super
competitive environment because guys
already know that their jobs are on the
line and they know that they're trying
to beat the next man
so you know that that's why i respect
the way he's the way he coaches and what
he's doing and i you know i love it man
i would shoot yeah i mean it's it's not
a zero-sum game right like if your
approach as a player is to say i'm gonna
play my heart out but i'm also gonna do
my best to bring out the best in the guy
standing right next to me or you know my
teammate who's you know right to my left
or my right uh everybody wins but you
know the human psyche doesn't always
operate that way yeah you know it should
yeah and how did you you know kind of
handle the mental aspects of of having
it you know
of kind of bouncing around from a bunch
of different teams and having to
relocate and all of that like how did
that go for you it's stressful but you
know that's like again that's part of
the game that's the job right yeah so
you just got to kind of roll with the
punches and and prepare and be just you
know as prepared as you possibly can
um
you know we don't buy a home anywhere we
just rent and you know now we're setting
up a home where we are now but
you know you just got to kind of just
stay on your toes and be ready to move
but you know that's how the game goes
right right right yeah so walk me
through the uh the typical diet
pre-vegan as an nfl player oh man all
right i know you love you love your
barbecue and that's what you grew up on
yeah i did yeah i grew up at a barbecue
restaurant my family owned oh wow yeah
so and we had a farm and we were at a
farm and my grandpa would go out there
and ring the chickens and then we would
eat it for breakfast wow where's the
farm it was in oklahoma
on it we would drive out every summer
and go out there and and spend the
summer in oklahoma and yeah
it was it was crazy a total 180
from when i am now but the the pre-game
diet
it was just kind of just basically i
didn't know anything about nutrition
before being vegan but it was just
basically eat whatever man people were i
was eating ice cream
most people do that that's actually as a
matter of fact the night before the game
we stay in the hotel the team serves hot
wings and spaghetti
oily
meat sauce and all that stuff and all
kind of crap and
like i said like ice cream shakes that's
the worst thing you can have before
working right like would you ever drink
that before
the night before a marathon like no
but you know that's that's the pre-game
and then uh the day before i mean the
day of
it's you know pasta and super dry steak
and it's been like that on every team
pasta and super dry steak like you like
it's so hard to cut
but
in like 81 steak sauce and then you go
out there and you play you play your
game
and then during the week when you're
just training similar like a version of
that yeah during the week like uh
for example when i was on the cardinals
i forget the name of the restaurant they
had catering in but it was or we would
get like papados they would have cater
and that papados is all like uh fried
shrimp and fried
uh alligator and fried fried everything
everything's fresh there's team
nutritionists right yeah but they're
bringing in fried food i mean it doesn't
matter if you're like whatever diet
you're on everybody pretty much agrees
that a bunch of fried food is no good
you guys are professional athletes yeah
and then there's some teams that you
know the nutrition is actually you know
the nutritionist does what they're what
they're supposed to do and the
nutritionists bring in like a lot of
fruits and veggies but then they bring
in like yogurt and all that stuff and
you know being a vegan i'm against all
that but you know people think that
that's what you're supposed to have and
that's good for you and all that and
that's it's really bad for you and it's
hurting you it's amazing that at that
level
you know of professional sports that
that's kind of how it functions you know
i just was
at uh a couple months ago i went and
spoke at the olympic training center
i spent a couple days there and in the
cafeteria at the olympic training center
in colorado springs where you know all
the top athletes and all these olympic
sports come and train
the cafeteria it's just you know
unlimited soda unlimited soft-serve ice
cream like all this junk food and i was
like what is going on like if anything
like this should be the place where at
least there's an opportunity where you
have these athletes that are you know
kind of
you know cloistered in this place for a
short period of time you could educate
them
i'm not saying like you know you and i
are plant-based but at least you know
get rid of the soda and the crappy you
know processed food yeah but you know
what when it comes down to is where's
their money coming from yeah you know
well coke is like mcdonald's is the
number one sponsor of the olympics right
right so right mcdonald's is also in
hospitals
they're paying hospitals too and
mcdonald's all right let's not get into
that we can get into that i know i talk
about that stuff all the time but yeah
yeah you and i know what's up with that
yeah um all right so uh so the latest
team that you're on uh is the jaguars
right and so when when was that was like
that was the last half ago yeah i was
last year and then it ended man running
back hit me in the knee popped my knee
really bad and torn mcl and then i
rehabbed on that but i held pretty
quickly
so but right now but that's got me in
spot right now i'm a free agent and you
know i'm just waiting for cam to start
and then i'm going to get on the team
during camp
for the jaguars well for whatever team
i see so that's how it goes like she's
just waiting for you waiting for your
asian to call you yeah basically yeah
but i did really well when i uh
when i was with the jags so and put up
some good numbers and show some good
film and all that stuff so
you know it's looking it's looking
really good right now yeah i want to get
into that in a little bit more detail
because there's kind of an interesting
story there that relates to
um you know this lifestyle shift that
that you have embraced so
uh you know where does that begin i know
paige is a long time vegan veggie
vegetarian vegan page
vegetarian vegetarian shift to vegan
uh-huh so paige were you vegetarian in
college
first year she was a meat-eater and she
read a skinny the book's title is called
skinny [ __ ] yeah skinny [ __ ] right
it's a good book
yeah i know the book yeah rory friedman
yeah and that was that kind of
kick-started everything and so yeah
and but but you know this is yeah i mean
you're playing ball like yeah that's
that's cool for her but like that's not
going to be your trip yeah man i was
like man you can forget that i'm not
good
yeah right you want me to do you don't
you cannot afford to be a skinny [ __ ]
right i can't be that's the opposite of
what you're trying to do exactly that's
funny but uh
yeah man so uh she went vegan like i
said i was like okay good job you know
you can do that by yourself i'm gonna
still keep eating this meat and keep
eating chicken i was eating like
four pieces of chicken in one setting
and you know
huge 84-hour steaks and all that stuff
we would go out to eat
but uh and in college you were pushing
what like two
sixty
two no that's my freshman year freshman
year at the end
senior year of college i was like 305
okay so
but uh
yeah man i was just eating eating
whatever yeah but uh and and you just
carry that into the nfl and that's how
you're playing and then and then
something happens and then uh so got
released from the from arizona and then
i was at the cowboys and i got released
from there i was i kept losing weight
and i was hurting i had injuries they
were just piling up i had why do you
think you were losing weight i don't
know man
i was like i got i was like 285
to 90 and i couldn't get my weight back
up but i was i was injured i had
shoulder pain because um
old injury was coming back from college
or i had dislocated my right shoulder
and then it was just getting kept
getting worse and it was at the
cardinals too it started hurting then
that's when it started hurting i had
nerve damage in my right arm i couldn't
feel my index finger middle finger and
ring finger and part of my thumb on my
right hand
couldn't like ball a fist they had me on
this huge brace and it would come
basically from my elbow all the way down
to like the knuckles of my right hand
and
like when i would try to hit someone i
couldn't really had no power in it it
was just like a limp and i was just
playing but i was still playing and i
was still doing well
but like when you can't exert yourself
then you're not able to work out to your
potential right so i would imagine that
had something to do with losing some of
the muscle mass yeah definitely but uh
and then i got released and from the i
finished the year out and i it was it
started you know after i left it alone
it started healing up and everything but
then uh
going i went to the cowboys and i was
playing there
and i got released from the cowboys
because i was still my weight i couldn't
get it back up again i was stuck at 285
290 and then i went to uh
that's after i got released from the
cowboys i went to uh
we
we were watching we were in dallas we
were in our apartment and we were
watching we were watching we were binge
watching netflix all the vegan uh
documentaries on netflix
what a night all right right so we were
watching i i i take it this is paige's
idea no no it well it was mine
i'm a little nerd right i'm a nerd on
the inside but what motivated you to
even want to watch those documentaries
yeah paige okay but we were watching uh
we were watching um
forks over knives
one of the many that we watched and um
and the doc was on there and he was
talking about how
at the time i was suffering let me go
back at the time i was suffering from
tendonitis
excuse me and
i would soak in the bathtub and now try
to lift myself up out of the bathtub and
it felt like somebody that would take a
bat to my elbows and i just i would like
almost collapsed and the pain was so
intense and so sharp
and it was time i was getting like
injections for that and on like a
battery of meds or yeah i had they were
giving me not injections but they were
giving me celebrex or knapperson or
something like that they were like it's
just tendonitis it you know it's nothing
you know the only way you can you can
get rid of that is celebrex and
celebrates man that stuff's so bad for
you like i hope i don't get sued for
saying that but that stuff's so bad for
you cause heart problems and all that
kind of crap but um
anyways and it wasn't doing anything and
arthritis too and arthritis arthritis
yeah arthritis high blood pressure
probably from the medication and what i
was eating
but
you know that stuff man it's so at age
like 25 yes that's the most scary part
right and i'm like why how the hell do i
have high blood pressure tendinitis and
arthritis or like i feel like arthritis
coming on i'm 25 years old like i've
lived like
hopefully a quarter of my life right now
so uh
yeah man i'm getting out of the bathtub
and it's like so much pain and elbows
hurting tendonitis really bad we're
watching the documentary forks over
knives and then that goes on and he goes
uh the the cause of inflammation
tendinitis people all these people are
suffering from tendonitis is milk and
like milk and meat and dairy is causing
all this it causes inflammation in the
joints
and then i was like wow is it really
that simple like am i is that the reason
why i was like i need to lay off the
meat that we kept watching the
documentaries
like uh cows not cow spirits he wasn't
out yet um frankensteer
and where the meat was coming from and
we were seeing i was seeing how they
spray all the cattle with pesticides and
they and 80
to keep the flies off of them and you
know all that crap that's in the
pesticides and 80 of antibiotics that
are supposed to go to humans go to
animals like all the ones that fda
or whoever didn't clear they go to the
animals and they feed them because
they're walking around their own [ __ ]
and so
you know and they eat their own [ __ ] and
they they cannibalize the cows and feed
them cow blood from the other cows that
died and other cows that died died of
just natural not natural sickness but
sickness they feed them those cows
so i was like man
it makes sense why
i'm not at you know the top of my game
right now
why my tendonitis is coming on like it
is or you know
so
after that you know i went vegan and
literally like that's amazing though
because i would think that at that
moment you're also thinking yeah but i
can't do i'm in the nfl man yeah i can't
like i hear that but like
if i go vegan i'm gonna lose all my
muscle like how am i gonna ever stay
strong how am i gonna keep the weight
you're having trouble keeping the weight
on as it as it was i was like well first
of all that's a pretty terrifying
prospect or pretty ballsy yeah it was i
was scared i was scared
i was really scared
but
i was like you know what i was like man
forget it you know like it said that
right now it's like this it's like if i
i can go vegan or i can just
suffer and like have tendonitis and
probably die at
like the average death of a football
player is 56 years old and most people
don't know that and that's from eating
all that crap and taking that heart
disease i mean heart disease heart
disease and stroke a lot of guys stroke
and so
i was like you know what forget it i'd
rather have quality of life then you
know then
keep playing and then hopefully keep
playing and then you know right just be
all in bad shape yeah you better be
careful who you who you mentioned that
to though because they're going to think
actually you got you have like a tbi
like a traumatic brain injury
considering going vegan no man that's
something's wrong with this guy's head i
got big balls that's what that is
but um you know uh
so i did a lot of research and i looked
up a couple of
uh bodybuilders of vegan bodybuilders i
was like that's the best place to start
and i saw that the strongest man in the
world or one of the strongest men in the
world is a vegan guy out of germany yeah
patrick patrick pavloomian yeah he's a
friend of mine and guy's awesome have
you met him yet no i want you to meet
him
i want to fly out to germany and see him
get some tips i was on stage with him in
toronto
at the veg fest a couple years ago when
he did that world record setting lift
1200 pounds for 10 meters i saw that i
made a little video of it yeah he's
super cool yeah the human wolverine yeah
he looks like him yeah yeah
but yeah he was one of the guys i saw
and i was like man
all right well he's not 300 pounds he's
like two he was like 265 yeah but he's
half he's half your height yeah
but and i was like [ __ ] if he's the
strongest man one of the strongest man
in the world
i can do it
like i can do it so i did more research
and then i was like because at the time
i was like man well where am i going to
get my protein from i need protein i was
one of those guys and then i was like oh
that just means you're pretty much
everybody basically yeah
but
uh you know as i started doing the
research and i went on the uh plant
built as a bunch of bodybuilders of
plant-based bodybuilders and they're
cool guys and i look i reached out to
guacamole and his and his uh wife and
they helped me out they sent me like a
marchessault
guacamole marches
my cheese i can't ever say his name
right i don't know but um
but they sent me they they helped me out
and they they sent me some uh
some tips and kind of took it from there
they sent me like a yeah tips i took it
from there and uh
i started doing more research and
learned all the plant-based proteins and
they were the highest forms of protein
and where i can get them and then i just
started from there and kind of you know
turned into like a plant-based scientist
and started testing out some of
how i can gain weight and where you know
where i can get the most energy from all
the plant-based foods and all that stuff
all right and so in the timeline this is
in the off-season yeah when you're
playing for the when you're playing for
the raiders no this is my cowboys this
is when i was yeah this is this is i got
released from the cowboys okay
in the off season and then
so
i meet this i have this trainer
while i'm in dallas i'm training for the
next season
and
he's uh he's not vegan at all a hispanic
guy and moses castro out of dallas texas
and uh great trainer and he wasn't vegan
and i told him i was like hey man i'm
going vegan he said wait a minute what
like what are you doing bro you're gonna
you're gonna lose all of your weight
you're gonna not be strong anymore where
are you gonna get your protein from and
i was like man just go with me on this
one and we're gonna see what happens
right
so
we did it i went vegan and then i ended
up losing weight but i was getting
stronger
i was uh my arms started healing up my
uh tendonitis just started disappearing
overnight i was like oh my gosh like i
can i was able to like do all kind of
push-ups and i was doing hundreds of
push-ups uh my bench press went up to
from like i was able before i was when i
was hurting the tendonitis i can only
bench press like 315 for like
four or five which is not a lot for me
right but
when i went vegan i lost weight but my
bench press went up i lost 40 pounds in
my weight and my bench press went up to
like 425 and then it went up to 435 and
465 eventually wow so yeah so initially
you you went down to about you probably
went down to about 260 255 yeah back
down did you have a little moment of
like oh [ __ ] yeah you know i freaked out
a little bit but then i started uh i had
to get back in the books and do some
more research and try to figure out how
to i had to boost my calories i talked
to guacamole again i had to boost my
calories and i had to do 10 000 calories
a day never in my life ever had to eat
10 000 calories a day and not on a vegan
diet that's the hardest thing in the
world a lot more food yeah
but um and your trainer when you lost
all that weight was he trying to talk
you out of it no he was i told him i
said look man i'm doing it i'm feeling a
lot healthier he was seeing the um
and he wasn't trying to change my mind
because he was seeing the improvements
as a matter of fact he went vegan oh wow
yeah he went vegan he was like he came
back one day he was like i see all the
improvements that you're making and i'm
decided i'm going vegan now that's
amazing yeah and he's uh now he's
running like crazy he's doing marathons
and stuff he's doing very well for
himself that's cool so
all right so so
you drop the weight and it's sort of
like you got to strip it all down and
build it back up again
right and as you're starting to slowly
put weight back on the bench press
numbers are going up squat numbers are
going up the tendonitis is going away
the arthritis is going away how about
the nerve damage in the arm nerve damage
gone the grip in my hands is doing
really it's gone
like i was able to
uh
do more than i've ever done before i was
stronger i felt like superman i was
stronger than i've ever been even when i
was you know my healthiest in college so
it
was perfect man it just went away that
the only thing i could say was vegan
diet and i know i sound like a vegan
spokesman i kind of where you are yeah i
really am
well what's interesting about that is
that a lot of people say especially with
um you know strong man and bodybuilders
and you know kind of power lifter type
guys that that go plant-based people
will say yeah well he you know he was
already big you know so he's just using
the strength that he already he already
had all that mass he put all that mass
on you know when he was eating the way
he was eating before so it doesn't
really count yeah but with you losing
the weight and then bringing it back up
again injury-free yes that's a different
story and a lot sexier than i was before
yeah
i mean whoa whoa whoa
paige he's sexier now
yeah yeah yeah man but yeah it is
awesome man like way less body fat i'm
way more a lot quicker than i was before
um
you know right so you put the weight
back on but the lower body fat so it's
actually you actually you probably had
added more muscle mass than you had
before definitely i i kind of have a
six-pack now i have a for 310 pounds i'm
looking really good i'm 310 right now
all right we'll get a picture of that
put it on the website for sure for
everybody to say so right on so so
meanwhile you're you're waiting for the
phone to ring right yeah and then uh the
raiders call and i go i ended up going
to the raiders we trained for that and
i'm going for the raiders i got my
weight up to like
um 290.
it wasn't exactly 300 i got my weight up
to 290
and um
um and hold on a second so what's the
average weight of like a defensive line
man or somebody in your position i mean
is it 300 is like yeah so that's kind of
like the bottom threshold yeah that's
like they're kind of like the cutoff
point you're going to try for a team for
you to play and d line you need to be
three plus
so unless you're playing like defensive
end where they're like small right right
yeah so
but um
but i signed with the raiders and then
um you know i went over there running
i was like it was impressive i was
running with the defensive with the
defensive backs and the wide receivers
and it was like they would be tired and
i'm like oh yeah i'm tired i'm right i'm
just going to go work out some more like
i had mad energy just from uh you know
eating i was eating good and
doing my vegan supplements and and all
that stuff and never got tired right and
yeah i think i read you were like
throwing down seven minute miles yeah
seven minute miles at 290 right now
it was impressive it's very impressive
actually but yeah and so are you
and you're open about the way that
you're eating right so what are the
other players saying what's the coach
saying what's the what are the team
trainers saying yeah well you know the
team trainers like they're like you know
where are you getting your protein from
and i'm like
i laughed i didn't mean to laugh but i
laughed
like
you can get protein anywhere man it's
all in this that the other you know
showing them like it's in the peas
there's more protein in a handful of
peas than there is in a full and a steak
and an eight-ounce steak and they're
like oh okay and they started seeing me
lifting the weights and lifting with the
lifting with the big guys and lifting
you know with the heaviest guys and
running with the smallest guys and
and they were over there timing me and
like i caught them timing me one time
they were like
and then i would go back around and run
another lap because we were running laps
and then they're like
and he's how heavy is he
and i'm running with the big with the
smaller guys and at the end of the run
the the smaller dbs will be you know
bending down and like
gasping for air
and i would go and just you know jog and
then go stretch out real quick and then
go lift weights again so
it was and that was oh that was my first
time being vegan coming back into coming
back into being on the team so it was
really good to that was a great feeling
to have and to
to
you know
and so are they just scratching their
heads going how's this possible or are
they thinking oh you must be doing
something else it can't be the it's the
first diet or yeah
because it's so
different than anything they've ever
been exposed to it must be it must have
been confusing for them it's a little
scary for them because you know it
challenges their way of life their whole
way of life because you know every every
dude is like
i'm a mediator you know being a three
being a football player you you know
that's the big manly macho thing is you
know eat eat steak eat red meat protein
shake
but
i'm doing it a totally different way
where you know i'm doing it on
plant-based you know
all that stuff and it challenges
everything you know like it's to the
point where
football teams are sponsored by like
muscle milk and
and hot wing companies and mcdonald's
and all that stuff so
yeah it is a it's a challenge it
challenges their way of life and it and
they're baffled by it because it's
something they've never seen before
right so but but in this case you're
strong you're injury-free you're killing
it in training camp everyone's taking
notice like where does this how does
this play out for you i mean where does
this go
so like you said everything's going good
but um
you know i just feel like the team
didn't take so kindly to it because you
know me being vegan like i said it's
different and it's
you know a lot of
a lot of people aren't used to that say
a week later this next monday i was i
was gone the team cut me so
you know
it was just it's a new thing for you
know being in my position being 300
pounds and
and totally obliterating idea that you
can't be big and strong and not and not
eat meat
it's different for teams and a lot of
guys who were trying to
we were looking into going vegan because
they weren't feeling too healthy they
weren't feeling they were the big guys
they weren't feeling their you know had
back problems and stuff and i don't
think they wanted that influence on the
team
you know the you know you can
you should probably stop eating so much
meat you should you know the influence
that uh that resolved your arthritis and
your tendonitis yeah that wouldn't be
good no no no getting healthy listen man
you know
that's the kind of unfortunate price
that somebody in your position who's
trying to break a paradigm has to face
in order to you know kind of break the
chain and open the door for you know the
next
wave of people to come through
somebody's got to be first yeah
and sometimes the guy who's first you
know becomes the casualty
yeah but you know it's
it's fun being the it's fun being the
underdog and it's fun it's interesting
being the guy who does it first like you
said and you know
there's a couple guys in the nfl now i
think right well yeah there's
yeah he's cool guys
yeah
tony gonzalez yeah that's right is he
still is he still vegan or i don't think
he's vegan anymore i think he's uh he's
back on chicken and stuff i don't know
don't quote me on that but
he he did vegan for a while and you know
that's big time to show that you can't
do it vegan he was a tight end a smaller
guy but he still did it man and he
you know [ __ ]
one of the greatest yeah and aaron
foster for a while but i think he's not
on it yeah he's not on it anymore but he
still did work very well while he was on
it too but yeah he seems like a cool
dude though yeah he's cool
all right so you get cut and it's uh
back to the drawing board i mean where
how do you pick that pick up the pieces
from that well i just concentrated on my
diet because you know
it was still in the beginning stages of
me not diet lifestyle it was still in
the beginning stages of me being vegan
so i was still experimenting on you know
how to get the best fuel you know how
that goes what to eat
uh
how am i going to gain all this weight
how the hell am i going to get to 10 000
calories 300 grams of protein a day 300
plus grams of protein a day so
that was a constant that was a
consequence
task in itself so um
i did that and i continued training and
i started working with my coach john
blake he's a coach out of dallas he
coached a lot of hall of famers in the
defensive line position
and um
uh
we created videotape sending out to all
the teams and ended up getting time with
the jacksonville jaguars and uh you know
i did very well over there
put up some good stats in the preseason
i was there
i put up some good stats and then
uh this was last this is last season
this past season and um
you know uh it's doing very well team
love me coaches love me they're like oh
you're doing great
and
they know about the vegan thing they
know about it and they were fine with
their cold and they were totally cool
with it see some teams are different
some teams are totally cool with it like
it's not a big deal as a matter of fact
we had another player on the team who
was vegan at that time and then ramsey's
barton he's a
wide receiver guy and um but anyway so
it must have been nice to have somebody
else that you could kind of bounce ideas
off of and yeah yeah definitely and i
was kind of we're sharing tips back and
forth and all that stuff but um
yeah totally fine with it and and it had
a lot of you know like i said a lot of
good stats a lot of good plays
um
one of the um
scouts came up to me was like man you're
doing so well right now a lot of the
teams are talking about you there's lots
of but there's a lot of buzz around the
league about you right now so i was you
know i was doing really good i felt
really good about what's going on
and um
then right the last preseason game i was
running uh scaling the crossing line
trying to make a tackle on the other
side of the line of scrimmage i mean on
the other side of the line and running
back was about to cross the the goal
line and i was i had my body turned a
little bit the wrong way and running
back went right into my knee and i
tore my acl
i was out for
like three months with that right there
that's pretty much the whole season
right yeah so i was done for the down
through the year off of that but
you know and i got a healed up pretty
quickly i healed up faster than they
thought i would but by then season's
full swing right right yeah so yeah so
you have yet to
have the opportunity to really
show what you're capable of yeah but
that's got to be sort of exciting but
also frustrating yeah it's very exciting
but it is very frustrating but i take it
this way you know
um
i have my ups and downs already you know
like i've not already i'm sure i'll have
more but i've done a lot of
experimenting and i feel very
comfortable with where i'm at right now
as far as strength goes as far as
agility goes and health everything goes
um
you know um
i figured i feel like i figured it out
how to
how to how to be
the 300 pound vegan the whole time like
300 pounds plus all the time like i said
right now i'm 310 before i was
struggling to keep my weight up the
heaviest you've been yeah that's the
heaviest i've been nice ever
so
but um
you know it's it's hard to gain the
weight
and as a as a vegan and that was the
really the major part of the struggle
how am i going to get this mask how am i
going to get this strength up um
well not really the strength that kind
of just came with it but um the size was
the hard part right so let's talk about
that uh you know sort of training
aspects aside
what's the typical day in the life of
food for you like breakfast lunch snacks
pre-workout post-workout dinner okay so
i'm on an interesting food schedule it's
nothing like yours
well we do different things yeah totally
different but
i eat on a two i have a timer every two
hours
and my timer goes off i'm eating is the
time we're gonna go off during this
podcast no no i'm gonna i got a bowl of
blueberries in front of you and a couple
almonds but i feel like i should be
feeding you more right now i'm good
right now
all right you can go get it just let me
know if you get hungry yeah thanks i
appreciate it but um
you had to reach the 10 count 10 000
calories a day
every two hours i'm eating eating
something or drinking a shake
um
and it's a lot of preparation so in the
morning i'll have like
uh berries or some kind of fruit
smoothie with with a bunch of bananas
that's an um that's another thing i'm
eating like 25 bananas a day not out
here because it's so hard to get organic
bananas out here in costa rica where
where i train at there's free bananas
everywhere so organic it's the greatest
site right right 30 bananas a day
program yeah and that's so many calories
in carbs which is great for gaining
weight but um
yeah so i do that and i do like a bowl
of millet or a bowl of couscous or
something like that soaked oats i soak a
lot of my uh soak a lot of my oats and
and nuts and stuff because it uh it
helps with digestion and absorbing as
much of the nutrients possible that's
another thing i'm constantly trying to
figure out ways to make food as dense as
possible and packed with nutrients as
possible that's where the vitamix comes
in oh you just blend it all down and
pack so much into it oh yeah
if it's greens or raw vegetables or
fruit or whatever you can get so much in
you so much more quickly yeah i use the
vitamix like crazy and i couldn't be
vegan without the vitamix right right
right so what is so so tell me what the
typical shake what's in the typical
shake
okay so the typical shake um everybody
wants to know that right i know right
like that's the scene you should be
selling this
but uh
the typical shake is
like oats um
was it wheat germ
like i said five bananas
um
and this is this is like one big shake
and i just drink it down like i'll drink
one shake and then wait 10 minutes and
drink another shake
but uh
i do that five bananas uh coconut cream
sunflower seeds and i just kind of mix
it all in there and then i get i try to
get
65 grams of protein per per like 64
ounce
container and that way i can get
i just drink it down half that's 30
grams of protein i drink that before
workout and i drink the other half after
a workout and then i just you know i
have like probably like i drink like
three of those 64-ounce containers right
right right and in terms of supplements
just like a plant-based protein
supplement like vega or sun warrior or
something like that well i use uh i use
vega before i use a lot of vaga before i
use their uh
but right now and health force i use a
lot of health force but right now i
don't i don't use
much of anything being out of um being
out of the country because can't really
get anything there and that's really
when i put on the most of my weight the
bulk of my weight i was using that's
interesting yeah when you when you
stopped doing the powders yeah when i
stopped doing the powders what do you
how do you explain that
just whole foods man just in dense foods
and less processed foods i'm not really
a huge fan of processed foods i mean
they taste good and they're great
transition for people trying to come
from you know the standard american diet
to the vegan diet
but you know there's not a lot of
nutrients in them you know but uh
they're but they're still very tasty
but um yeah so do you when you when you
stop doing all the powders
you didn't notice a difference in your
ability to
recover or
build mass or keep weight on put weight
on yeah
i stopped using the powders and
um and once again i lost a little bit of
weight but
i put the weight back on again
not too much weight like 10 pounds so i
was like 290. and i was like oh my gosh
no i need to get back up again so but
i put on i put on the weight and i was
becoming more cut more defined
uh stronger
um
i was doing 200 push-ups a day before
and then when i started doing more whole
foods i was doing like i was like after
my 200 okay i'm gonna do 300 i'm gonna
do 400 and i'm doing like 500 push-ups a
day like wow and just it's got a lot
easier because i feel like
eating the whole foods your body can
utilize the nutrients more when you're
eating so many processed foods
it's hard for your body to break that
down your body's confused and doesn't
know really what to do with it
uh
and it changes your gut biome too yeah
definitely so you you know when you're
eating all the whole foods you're
propagating a certain kind of of you
know microbiology in your gut that's
that acclimates to
those kinds of foods right so you're
maximizing that by only eating those
yeah definitely and then that's another
thing speaking of gut bio um i would
when i went out to costa rica i got the
privilege of meeting victorious
kubinskis and he's uh you know that is
oh yeah he's awesome but uh john
joseph's always talking about that guy
yeah he's amazing he's full of knowledge
but anyway that's the guy who got me
doing 200 push-ups a day and there are
500 push-ups he's doing 200 push-ups a
day he's 72 years old i think maybe i
think he's older than that
but he's got scoliosis he's blind and
he's doing 200 push-ups a day
and
i was like and he was like
oh yeah david i'm doing 200 push-ups a
day i was like are you serious i was
like i challenge you i said okay
i was like i cannot let this 72 year old
guy beat me in a push-up competition
so now i have to double it and add an
extra hundred on there but anyways
um back to the the gut bio or get and
get you know the gut and science
i learned from him how to make uh
probiotics and so i've been making my
own probiotics and
sauerkraut and all that stuff and and a
wealth of knowledge and it's amazing how
if you have the the the right probiotics
you taking them like you're supposed to
be you utilize all the the food like
you're supposed to be your body can
digest them right you're more of those
nutrients become more bioavailable to
you
just passing right through you exactly
you have so much more energy skin clears
up my muscle definition uh clears up
everything clears up
the definition came about a lot better i
got bigger i felt myself i
started weighing myself i was putting on
like five pounds every two weeks so it
was and it was like solid i wasn't
putting on any fat so it was really good
right and what about recovery oh man
recovery is great so one of my workouts
is when i'm in costa rica as i take a
bag a big huge burlap bag and how big it
is
like and i fill it up with rocks
and
and so what i do is i take this bag and
i do i carry it in front of the front of
my body like this i carry it like a
person and i just carry it up the hill
and i do that
all day and i'll never get tired and my
like
it's it's amazing i run all day like the
stuff that used to make me tired before
when i was doing a lot of the pro like
processed foods and stuff
um
you know it it doesn't tire me out
anymore like the oxygen is just free
flowing in my body i utilize oxygen a
lot better recovery time i don't get
sore after workouts at all anymore
uh i see a lot of people post on
instagram like about how oh yeah on leg
day if it was a leg day and the zombie
attack happened you know i'm done
right but my legs never get tired
and and my legs are i literally
what's the squat in the leg press these
days
uh the squat i'm squatting like uh just
the other day uh yesterday or day before
i squat leg press 600 pounds 10 times so
it's just working out it's working you
know 600 pounds you know
all right but yeah but uh squat is like
600 so it's it's doing i'm doing really
well like that's some of the highest
numbers i've ever had so i'm really
impressed with what i'm able to to to
churn out on this uh in this vegan
lifestyle right all right well back to
like the food timeline so we're through
breakfast right now okay so how does it
work like snacks lunch pre-workout
afternoon workout after you work out
dinner okay so
snack okay pre-workout i get my workout
pre-workout i do uh maca maca powder
and um spirit unlike a mixture maca
powder spirulina
and uh
marenga and moringa is the that's like
the superfood superfruit of all super
fruits like uh
plays every position yeah you know
awesome awesome stuff and it seems to
give me a great energy boost before
workouts and it keeps me going and um
because it also has protein in it too
right so but um
it keeps me it keeps me going
keeps me going for the whole workout
lots of energy and it's like um so
that's my pre-workout and um
and then during the workout i actually
put spirulina in my water that's like my
little secret i take it puts water in
the vitamix put some spirulina in there
maybe a little bit of moringa and i
blend it up and it tastes like crap but
it does it does great because you're
feeling
your body you're working so hard in the
gym at least me or i work so hard in the
gym my body needs some fuel some
nutrients to to kind of
supplement while working out
and it does a great job it just gives my
body that protein right now that it
needs during the workout spirulina is
the highest protein content by weight of
any food on the planet yeah 60 protein
and uh i do that in the morning too but
i'll put a little i'll squeeze some
lemon in it to make it and actually
taste a lot better if you do that
but it's incredible how you just
immediately feel good it's just water
spirulina and a little lemon and you're
like
boom zing you know yeah yeah yeah yeah i
never talked to anybody else that did
that though so
i thought i was the only guy doing that
because for most people like it's
unpalatable yeah you know it's not like
it tastes good yeah i'm gonna have to
try the lemon thing but yeah it does
taste like like ass
sorry for all the christmas but yeah
that's all right man it's a podcast oh
say whatever you want all right cool
cool um all right so that's like during
workout and then i assume like after
workout another shake
yeah what you do so after workout i take
another shake down probably like 500
calories because i'm lifting heavy
weights so and i'm trying to gain weight
i don't want to just take a shake down
that's going to be just enough to refuel
my body so
i mean like just enough to barely meet
my muscle mass and all that stuff so i'm
drinking
uh at least 30 or 30 not at least 30
grams because your body can only process
30 grams of protein after you work out
or 25 grams of proteins i do like 30
grams shake of protein and then i do
and then i do 500 calories it's a
combination of bananas
oatmeal
wheat germ like i said i put some flax
seed in there also do flaxseed before
workouts because that actually helps
your body to burn fat um fat your fat
energy stores for energy during the
workout prolonging your workout making
it
much i have great workouts when i use
flax seed
so um and it also lowers your blood
pressure for guys who have high blood
pressure problems and i used to have
high blood pressure so i'm always taking
it but right is the blood pressure good
now oh yeah blood pressure is fine
i don't have any problems with it
but um
yeah after workout so bananas flax seed
uh oats
so i do soaked oats because adam that
they're pretty much more digestible
right away
and uh
yeah what about beans and legumes that's
more like a dinner thing i'll put beans
in there sometimes a lot of times in
your blend yeah oh you blend them up in
your drink it's protein
i've never done that how does that taste
well i put black beans in there
sometimes and it's not very pretty
but i usually do white beans or
something like that and then you know at
least it looks nice but it's the same
amount of protein
and it's got a lot of calories a lot of
fiber in it and that's another good
thing too fiber is good for muscle
development a lot of people don't know
that they have fiber deficiencies and
that's why they're not building muscle
something they think is protein but it's
really you don't have enough fiber in
your system but um
yeah so i do that that's
beans bananas flex flax oats and wheat
germ what about uh you ever do beets i
do beats
before workout pre-workout
yeah
man dude it's like that's crazy how much
better you feel like you feel like you
just every breath you take in is like
three breaths yeah definitely i learned
that from uh paul shapiro who's a good
friend of mine uh oh at humane society
yeah yeah good friend of mine here i owe
him a workout he's like i want to work
out with you i don't know if you can
hang bro but uh okay
we went to the same high school really
yeah yeah i mean i'm way older than him
but uh but i know paul oh he's cool he's
cool him and his brother i call him his
brother like the vegan ramble that guy's
got like a
case out against the fbi and all him
right yeah
it's a hardcore situation yeah i met his
dad you know like grew up in a really
conservative family but when he was like
when he was in high school he had crazy
dreadlocks and you know like growing up
in dc like that like that's radical you
know he was always like an activist dude
yeah they're cool i like them man
they're great people what we were
talking about we're talking about dinner
dinner oh yeah and we weren't but we are
now we are yeah that's where we're
heading yeah but uh
dinner my one of my favorite things is
uh gaio pinto which is
um
beans and rice because beans and rice
comprise of a complete protein most
people don't know that
but uh it's very filling plenty of carbs
plenty of calories plenty of fiber
plenty of protein
and
i usually add avocado tomatoes
and uh some some
queso on there and make that in the
vitamix with the nutritional yeast which
is a complete protein and also has b12
in it too plenty of b12 for recovery and
all that stuff and uh
and
and uh the cashews yeah they have
there's so many calories it's like it
helps you to i feel like that helps to
put on so much weight with the
nutritional yeast and
and the cashews and all that stuff we
make cashew cheese and vitamix with with
uh nutritional yeast and cashews yeah
you done that oh i do it all the time
that's my favorite i do like every day i
know like who am i talking to exactly
you know what's funny about i mean i
could eat beans and rice every single
day i pretty much do you know like i'm
pretty simple like
i like it like i could have that for
dinner every night just that with like a
little avocado and some hot sauce and
like i'm good yeah and when people say
oh man you know plant-based so
complicated so expensive it's like it's
so simple buy a huge bag of rice and a
huge bag of beans and you're out like 10
bucks and you can eat for like a month
exactly i don't know that's something
and it takes 10 minutes to make yeah
like
expensive like that's like the poor
man's gonna get fruit during the day and
i'll eat that like for lunch and dinner
i honestly i could like be happy with
that yeah yeah as long as i have a
vitamix too but yeah i mean you can make
anything a vitamix but
sometimes i make like bean soups just
pour a bunch of beans in there like
white beans and
and then put a bunch of seasonings in it
some like a pumpkin or whatever and then
it's like protein packed like um
yam protein beans and yams and that's
like it's sweet put some vanilla in
there you don't even taste the the beans
when you you have the yam in there it's
super sweet it's like a thanksgiving
treat or something like that it's
awesome it takes like no time to make no
time but it's full of nutrients yeah
yeah all right so i got a pretty clear
what about desserts
i'm not a real dessert guy no i don't do
desserts
oh banana and ice cream fruit yeah
that's my fruit or banana nice cream
that's like i feel like i'm eating ice
cream but i'm not but it's just bananas
it's awesome
that's good so all right i get it um
and i want to uh i want to get into the
whole costa rica thing because uh you
kind of went down there with one idea of
what was going to be up and it seems
like it's turned into a different thing
man like suddenly you're living down
there
yeah well we're not living down there
we're living down there kind of but
we're going to live down there
permanently after everything's all said
and done but right now we went out there
to go with our tim
with our friend tim
and he's a great guy animal activist he
works with a health force
um
he's cool he's got this huge vegan
tattoo across his neck oh wow yeah he's
he's about that life but um
he uh we went out there to go visit him
and you know work with he has this thing
called uh
project that way out and it's a turtle
farm and they save turtles and it's most
turtles they're 10 000 turtles born and
one of them will survive so they're
going extinct
so he does that he saves turtles but
while we were out there we met this girl
named allison
alice ali and she's awesome great friend
of ours but uh
she goes to the school called uh
futuro verde and it's a you know pretty
forward-thinking school in costa rica
but um
it's a private school an ib school in
the baccalaureate school
so they're doing very well
but uh they asked me to do a speech
there and talk to them about
veganism and what it entails
and um
i went there and i spoke to the kids
like the little baby kids
and now it's the most frustrating thing
i've ever done it's so hard to speak to
little kids like
first second grade it's hard to connect
yeah especially about nutrition you know
like what's calcium yeah it's like you
gotta you gotta find a way you gotta
find a way in with kids yeah right
that it's not easy yeah definitely but
then i spoke to the high school kids uh
you know
the upper grades and after that and i
told them about everything how natural
flavors what they're really made of did
you know that the natural flavors like
one of the major ingredients in natural
flavor they derive from beaver butt
i had heard that i mean the word natural
means nothing yeah it means absolutely
nothing it basically means it's in it's
in the three-dimensional world pretty
much
yeah but uh yeah so i talked to them
about that talk to them about how i
became vegan and you know the things
that i eat and all that stuff and how
they can start transitioning into the
vegan diet and how it would be good for
them and how it's cheaper to eat a vegan
diet as well that was one of the things
that i pitched to them the next thing i
know the school is like oh yeah you know
we want to um start we were impressed by
your presentation we want to start
implementing you know vegan into our
meal plans at the school and it started
with one day we pitched them like uh
meatless mondays which is a program that
they do out here in the states is
meatless mondays it works pretty well
but
we went and talked to them we told them
how you know they can save money doing
this we're saving money
uh
having vegan meal plan and and how it's
going to be better for the students and
all that stuff they're doing three days
a week now
vegan
vegan menu and uh that's pretty good
seeing that that's the actually that's
the first school in costa rica to become
vegan wow so
but costa rica is a pretty interesting
place i mean you know it's incredibly
progressive they have no
they have no like army right like they
have like no
uh sort of military setup and you know
they're on the cutting edge of organic
farming i mean it's basically like an
incredibly
vegan plant-based friendly place to live
might be the most on the whole planet
yeah it's probably the way they function
it's pretty vegan but at the same time
um
they're big like
agriculture people like they're all
about like where we are it's montezuma
costa rica and the nikoi peninsula
and uh one of the blue zones yeah one of
the blue zones but it's really like you
said there's a lot of vegan people out
there but it's not like you said there's
organic farming and there's a few vegan
people out there but it's really like
you know grass-fed cows and all that
that's what they're big on right now
right because sustainable agriculture
yeah sustainable agriculture but that's
what you know that's what they're that's
what they make their livelihood on is
selling
selling meat
and selling cows and they're very
religious out there and veganism is
comes across as a as a religion being
vegan comes across as a religion to them
out there and they're like oh no
but to have that as a in one in any of
the schools in costa rica
in latin america
is pretty impressive and the humane
society international is involved in it
now and they're helping them revamp
their menu
and eventually the school is going to go
completely vegan all five days wow vegan
which is very impressive and i'm really
thankful for that and that's awesome
that's pretty cool that's just like uh
muse um the camera suzy cameron susie
and uh susie
amos cameron and and her sister rebecca
susie's the wife of james cameron the
film director and their school muse is
right on the other side of that hill
really right behind here it's pretty
cool you should go and they have a um
thing called muse talks it's kind of
like uh they do like a ted talks thing
where they bring speakers in to speak
you would you would be great you should
go and you should go and give a talk
there i think i might i'm gonna try and
hit them up oh you should i'll i'll
introduce you uh our uh
i get i did it rick esselstyn's done it
neil barnard's been there they just said
sir ken robinson like they get some
pretty cool people but you would be
great and they're gonna um they're
instituting the first you know all
plant-based lunch of any school in the
country it starts next year i mean they
already eat
they have plant-based every day but they
have some other options because they
just felt like they had to for the
parents but next year it's full
plant-based they're growing all this
food there it's it's an amazing place
i'm sure you've seen your kids so that's
cool
well we've been um we've homeschooled
all our kids oh yeah yeah yeah but
our two uh youngest our two little girls
they were kind of at a point where it
was becoming apparent that that they
could benefit from a little bit more
structure
um and there were certain things that
they wanted to explore and they seemed
to have an interest in in checking it
out and like you know we've known susie
for a while and we're kind of connected
to that school so it just made sense so
literally just like three or four weeks
ago they they went there to just kind of
go for the end of this year and see how
they liked it but they're enjoying it i
mean it's amazing it's like solar
powered and like all this kind of stuff
is like doesn't exist in any other
school yeah it's pretty cool but um
i'll make sure that i introduce you to
them because you would be cool you would
be great appreciate it but that mean but
that means that you can't just go hide
out in costa rica all the time right no
we're coming back out here man
that's like temporary we're just setting
up for the future but but you went down
there to like go visit some friends and
did you just stay or did you come back
have you been kind of going back and
forth well we're coming back and forth
but we stayed out there for a pretty
long time it's so amazing but you know
we can't get any work done in costa rica
it's they don't even have really
internet
so
uh we're coming back out here and uh
to l.a this is our hometown then we're
coming back out here get some work done
and you know 300 pound vegan is growing
and we're trying to do some things so
literally and figuratively yeah
definitely right yeah like
yeah
so but you just need that phone to ring
yeah but i'm sure how's it looking i
mean do you have any do you kind of have
a sense of how it might play out right
now yeah it's looking good like i said
before i got hurt i was doing very well
and you know i had a lot of put up a lot
of stats and you know i was impressed
with myself oh man i'm doing this on
vegan diet this is great but uh
i actually was doing better than i was
when i first came in and at any time in
my career so you know it's just uh right
now it's just a waiting game so we'll
see we'll see what happens in august
when the camp starts right and most guys
in your position would be working with a
trainer every day at a gym
you know doing that kind of traditional
route but you're down in costa rica
doing this kind of primal functional
body strength you know swinging from
trees and carrying rocks around and
stuff and like doing push-ups on the
beach with the 72 year old guy right so
how does that work when
you know
you don't have that that kind of
familiar accountability to another
person and it's kind of all on you to
get up in the morning and figure out
what you're going to do to you know take
care of yourself and put you in a
position where when you get that call
you're ready to show up and play
uh you know it's it's a challenge it
makes you
it makes you you have to be accountable
to yourself like you don't have i don't
have an accountability accountability
partner i have to get up in the morning
and get out there before it gets too hot
and work out by myself
and uh
before i left i work i sat down with my
trainer and my defensive line coach my
pastor's coach who i work with and um
i worked out a workout plan with the two
of them and you know i had i got that
down before i went out there but then i
started adding my own stuff but it for
when i when you're out there by yourself
and you're working out like that by
yourself
and doing it all by yourself you have to
push yourself it's a it's a mental thing
and you know like when you're running
and you're running 100 miles
you know you have to push yourself and
no one's going to do it for you and uh
that was kind of like a like a crutch
that you had when you're working with
the trainer in the stadium
to slack somebody'd be on your back yeah
but when you're doing it you got to push
that weight off your chest by yourself
you know you got to carry that weight
the rest of the way when i'm carrying
that huge back of rocks or pulling that
tree down the beach i have to
i have to do it myself i have to
motivate myself to do it and you know
it's a
it's physical training but it's also
mental training as well yeah it's
awesome well let's get into that part uh
i know that like
yoga and meditation is kind of a thing
that you've gotten into right so how did
that start and how has that kind of
impacted your perspective oh yoga is
awesome i think it's uh like it's
clears the mind and it it fixes the body
it creates space within the body and i
sound like a yogi i'm not yeah
like straight up you're like unlike any
other football player i've ever met oh
thank you i appreciate that yeah i mean
that's a that's that's a good thing you
know but
it's not normal for you know an nfl guy
to start you know waxing poetic about
like yoga and meditation man it should
be yeah it should right it's like like
nutrition should be a very huge thing in
sports and nutrition but we already
discussed that but it's not but uh yoga
man it's awesome it creates space you
get to you you get to know your body you
get to you're like having a conversation
with your body when you're doing yoga
and you get to go into those deep places
like
my shoulder for example my shoulder
injury
doing all those uh
downward dog stances and and doing all
those poses and and stretching and
planting my hands into the ground
um
it was uh
that stuff opens up your stuff it makes
you use those muscles that you've never
used before being a big man
it's hard to get into those poses and
the crane poses and stuff at 310 pounds
but uh
and it really and that's another mental
mental strength thing you got going on
right there it forces you to push
yourself to places if you've never been
before
and where did it where did it begin for
you and what was your entry point into
yoga uh my beginning point was uh
shoot when i first got into the league
page you made me start doing videos yeah
yeah i had a feeling you were gonna do
yeah so you made it good come on man i
gotta know what to start doing no but
like where i knew that that's i had a
feeling that's what you were going to
say which kind of leads me to the next
thing that i was going to
talk about which is
you know the importance of having like a
strong supportive partner who is like
pushing you to grow and expand because
dude i mean left to my own devices like
i'm a jack in the box yeah i mean like
my wife was really
you know she wasn't
fully plant-based she wasn't fully vegan
but she was leading a healthy lifestyle
and had
you know healed herself of a cyst
in her neck
um using ayurveda and she was into yoga
and meditation and reading spiritual
texts and always kind of like trying to
expand her horizons and grow and you
know i just wasn't interested you know
it's like it took me i had to get to a
place where i was in like a lot of pain
in order to start listening but
but
having that partner who's kind of you
know willing to help and
and standing in their strength like in
the light has been transformative for me
yeah definitely and it sounds like
you've got definitely have the same
thing yeah definitely taking me to a
place where i never i know you even
thought about giving paige mike sitting
over there all quiet all right all right
she's good i think right but i mean
she's you know listen she was the entry
point into these nutritional shifts yeah
yoga yeah same with meditation yeah same
with meditation i was like mind racing
like i'm not trying to sit down i'd
rather sit down and watch television or
something or play
you know football games or whatever
go work out whatever i'm not going to
sit there and do nothing for 30 minutes
and just breathe like okay
right and just like i said mine racing
but it is it's amazing
how
you know you think that doing a bunch of
stuff is probably i'm being productive
and being productive no you you sit down
and you relax
and you you know you think about you
don't even think about anything but it
just it helps you to grow and that's the
easiest way to grow is met through
meditation i was talking to one of my my
teammates about it he
he was like man
you know he's like because i tell him
all the time bro you should meditate you
should do yoga he said i'm trying to
make him vegan he's like he's now he's
talking i'm gonna be vegan but now he's
like you know uh
hey man you know you should meditate i'm
like man i'm the one that told you that
he's like he's telling he's like oh you
should have i'm thinking about going
vegan you know that i'm like man i'm the
one who told you that but
it it's it's great man it does a lot of
good things for for your mind for your
body for your soul
i think it even helps you to heal
injuries you know just
the power of the mind to heal power of
the mind yeah now we're getting all new
age i know right right how about that
namaste um so how does how does that how
does that look for you i mean what is
there a particular type of meditation
that you do or
you know no i haven't gotten all into it
like that and just kind of just relax
and i just clear my mind i sit down in
my yoga pose and just
i do it and it is not just still
meditation when i'm doing my my yoga i
sit and i meditate or you know you
meditate anywhere really as long as you
just
sit down relax and clear your mind and
just
just get rid of all the world stresses
that you have the day stresses which you
have don't think about what you have
going on in the future don't think about
what's troubling you from the past
and just
you know that stuff it it works it's
it's calming and that's the best thing
most people don't get the chance to have
that in the day right and and they may
think that like oh well you're in costa
rica you know i'm stuck on the 405 while
you're sitting on the beach you know but
the truth is
it's just a choice that you make yeah
you do it wherever you want to create
your own world right yeah but it
probably is easier in costa rica it's a
lot easier i'm not going to deny that
yeah
um
how do you
handle
well actually before i get into that i
wanted to ask you
because it kind of falls on the heels of
the spiritual aspects of you know
the the things that you're kind of
stepping into and growing into
which is the ethical side of being vegan
i mean initially you you made this
switch because you were injured and you
wanted a healthier way of you know sort
of being a football player and now you
have
a different perspective or maybe i
should say a more expanded perspective
because you know you're a pretty
passionate animal rights advocate and it
didn't start out that way so i'm
interested in how that kind of came
about
yeah
well definitely once i went vegan
initially was like you said just for
health reasons but then uh
when i realized you know
we don't need meat at all to survive and
i was pushing up big numbers in the gym
and running well and
and put on putting on more weight than i
ever had before
you realize that you know the only real
reason to eat animals animals is for
greed
you know
and
like you you know i remember you said
that it's the middle man you're the
middle man i mean the animals are the
middle man and we're stealing from that
yeah i mean
i think there's this idea that were that
were uh obligate omnivores that we must
eat meat and so you know sort of
livestock agriculture is just a
necessary
thing that we have to do but once you
realize
we're not obligate omnivores it's a
choice and we can
not only survive but actually thrive
without them it's impossible to not go
well if that's the case then like what
are we doing yeah it's it's a it's an
old it's an old concept that we need to
eat meat you know like people will
assume that we're
like you said we're we're carnivores and
we're we're
we're not you know like our intestines
are not made for it all right we don't
have claws we don't have large fangs you
know we can't run down a deer and chase
them down you know none of that stuff
you know and so
it's it's science man like we're not
made to to eat meat at all and really
you know
the more people find that out then
you know the better the world's going to
be and i feel that
people are just
people are just unaware and because of
that animals are dying every day by the
billions and everything like
and it's it's not just food it's
everything it's uh for example soap
most people don't know they look on that
soap is made from from dogs
like what yeah wait i didn't know this
hold on a second so that can't be true
in the united states what do you mean
made from dogs made from dogs bro like
okay come on so soap if you look on the
back of your soap there's going to be an
ingredient on the back of the soap
glycerin glycerin basically it's just a
scientific term for okay this is what
they do all the dogs that are in the dog
pound they get put to sleep they take
them and they got to go somewhere
they're not really not not burning them
up incinerating them or burying them
somewhere they're taking them they take
them to a factory somewhere they boil
them
and they the fat that comes from the um
from the dogs and whatever other animals
they put in there cats dogs
uh whatever they just take the fat off
skim it off the top and they make
glitter that's glycerin that's the i
didn't know that they make the soap out
of it so most people don't know that
every time they wash their hands
and putting dead dog fat on their hands
so it's and it makes you think like man
what other what other things are we
utilizing animals for that they don't
need to be utilized for dogs are being
put to sleep
and then being caught by the dog pound
and they're like finding reasons to kill
dogs you know i know it's a lot of them
but damn like you know guys you don't
got to kill all of them yeah yeah yeah
so and so but where does this where does
this creep in is this just a natural
evolution of you kind of realizing like
oh wow i'm actually doing really well
yeah without me and it just naturally
led you to question these paradigms or
like a book that you read or you know
yeah because this has become like the
main part of who you're all about what
they're all about
i read the book uh mad cowboy
and
meet us for i met a read a couple but
bad cowboy where that's the
and meat is for [ __ ] and
and um
i forget the name of the other book but
a really good book and it on talks about
all the things that they do
that
it just
just totally just not necessary to the
animals for example animals that we eat
the
that that they eat those people and that
they eat that you know the pain and the
suffering that they go through
and that's totally unnecessary and
when you when you take when you take a
step back and you realize that wow like
all this is going on just so i can have
a steak you know they're raping cows to
have other cows
leather sheets in my car or whatever
yeah yeah yeah or yeah that's another
thing the death march where they take
the cows and they they march them all
the way they can't kill them in india
because they're like you know they're
honored the cows are honored so they
death march them they walk up yeah
across the boundary line yeah man that's
wild and just so they can kill him at
the end yeah and when you realize that
all that stuff and how unnecessary it is
especially when we don't need animals to
survive in any capacity it's 2015. we
don't need leather seats in our car we
can make a composite leather out of
whatever and use that or not compile but
you know we can make
um yeah there's all k i mean it's 2015
there's a million kinds of modern
textiles that yeah
we don't really have to use that we just
like the way it smells exactly what it
feels we like our steak it makes us feel
regal you know that's where we're
masculine i mean
you know masculinity is a big part of
this whole thing too and and that's why
i think you're such a powerful example
like being a football player and you
know being a 300 pound guy you know
because
men associate their sense of identity
with these sorts of things you know it's
like they got to have their steak
because it's not just it tastes good
that's part of it but but there's
there's a there's a gender identity that
comes with that and and when you kind of
speak to that it becomes very
threatening or destabilizing and it's
one thing for like a skinny ultra runner
guy to talk about it's a very different
thing for you know a guy who can throw
up 400 plus pounds on the bench press
and is playing in the nfl to talk about
it yeah
yeah that's the thing that and it does
make a difference you know like
i was talking to somebody about it
yesterday and they're like why why do
most men feel that they have to be
uh eat meat to be a man and that is is
true that's what a lot of guys think 99
of the men in the world think that
and
you know they feel like
i know most guys i don't know like i'm a
man this is only protein in here i got
to eat this animal you know good at the
blood and it's you know it's like
they're being some kind of warrior yeah
some carnivore and i know that's not the
case no you're you don't have to eat
this innocent animal first of all you
couldn't go hunt that animal down if you
wanted to yourself anyway like i said
you don't have the unless you if you
took away the
ralphs and they're getting it in
cellophane yeah or the whole foods yeah
you know you know you're not you're not
hunting the whole hunter gatherer
concept is out of you know that's out
the window you're not doing any of that
you're grocery shopping
but you know am i so you're not really
being that's not really manly that's you
know opportunist like you're out there
it's convenient to go get the meat in
the store and you're just feeding
whatever getting eaten whenever somebody
tells you i think part of it also is
that you know a lot of men feel
emasculated because of the way our
society is set up you know
you're stuck in a job you hate you're
sitting in a cubicle like you're not
you're not living the life of like a
primal man so it's one way of saying
well at least when i do this it makes me
feel manly even if it's a complete
illusion or or fallacy
um
because it runs deep man it's like a
it's like a powerful emotional thing you
know and it that's why i think it's so
tough
for so many dudes to wrap their head
around like the idea of embracing this
lifestyle it's just it's super scary and
threatening because
because they associate it with with
undermining their manhood yeah and the
truth is like real manhood true
masculinity i think is protect yeah it's
being compassionate it's taking care of
of those that can't take care of
themselves exactly exactly and
not only that like being around to
protect your family you know
yeah right
yeah like you said protecting your
family let's get on that if you die of a
heart attack at 50 and you're not around
for you know you can't protect your
family i'm not taking care of them
exactly and then not only that bro like
think about this like you know you have
your kids you have kids you're like you
know what's in that now if you were to
inform yourself what goes into what goes
into a steak like you have all those
antibiotics you have all those
pesticides you have all those drugs and
everything that they pump into the cows
pigs whatever
and
you cut that up you go buy it in the
store you cut it up you put it on a
plate and you feed it to your child
you're not protecting your child you're
harming your child and that's you know
your wife and that's you're not
protecting anybody you're you're
poisoning them you're allowing
big agriculture or whatever
the big farm companies are you know all
these companies to to poisoning your
child or your your wife yeah that's a
good point yeah so that's not being
manly at all man that's being that's
being
i'm not trying to be too aggressive here
but that's being stupid right you know
like you
so what do you how do you address it
when you the other guy the guys that you
train with other football players dudes
you see in the gym who are you know
probably rolling up on you oh hey man
dave carter playing the nfl like oh you
know oh vegan really like while i'm on a
paleo diet like it's working for me or
you know what's wrong with paleo because
like it's all about paleo now that's
like the big craze yeah i was trying to
create some confusion so yeah like how
do you navigate those conversations
so
i tell them first like one of the
biggest things that i like to tell them
is that like man that's cool you know
you you're eating cleaner than
i don't know you're eating cleaner than
a lot of people but
bro like
do you understand how the human body is
designed like your human body is not
designed to eat meat in any capacity
like you're
interested i'll just tell you you're cr
you're wrong about that yeah like man
it's science look it up like google it
like the internet is right there at your
fingertips but the internet is is full
of all kinds of conflict and confusing
information it's not always like
this the solution to like google
something because for every study you
find you can find a conflicting study
and then once you read the whole thing
and figure out who paid for it and you
have a background in science where you
can understand like whatever bias is
built into whatever study on either side
of the equation and then yeah then you
know your whole day's over and you know
what i mean like you can go down that
rabbit hole forever it is it is a
challenge to to go against
those people who are they're just so
gung-ho about staying on the paleo diets
thing eating meat they're just it's like
a drug rhythm you know they're trying to
find any reason to stay eating meat
but you know
what i do is i tell them you know i tell
them about that how is scientifically
humans are not designed to eat meat or i
read to them the heart disease rates and
stroke rates and what would directly
correlate it to meat consumption and
dairy consumption and how
the for example the milk company this is
one thing i love to tell how they're
like oh you remember that commercial got
milk commercial of course how could you
forget it's like permanently tattooed on
my brain i mean it would be impossible
to not know what that was exactly or and
they're like milk does a body good and
all that stuff well legally they can no
longer say that because
they crack down on them and there's been
studies that have been done and they're
like well they they say oh milk is good
for you milk is good for you well
legally no it's not
like it's
they they can no longer say milk does a
body good because it does not so they
can get sued for that that's
they changed the slogan from milk does
the body good to protect milk to get to
got milk and protein and milk has
protein in it and so like
like you know people they they don't
they don't know about these things
because those things are hidden and milk
companies do a great job of hiding that
stuff and and
like you said the the meat companies
they do a really good job of hiring
teams of of researchers to generate
false information
and false studies to to argue these
harvard studies that have proven that
meat it causes heart attack you know
coagulates the arteries and causes heart
attack and stroke and all that stuff
and
you know but
you just have to i like to plant seeds
in people's mind and and tell them like
you know like
just look for yourself man do the
research you know i've done the research
and one of the things is they they
like you can see you can by looking at
me that you know you're not going to get
weak and small by being a vegan so let
that be enough man and do some research
and watch some documentaries and and
find out for yourself and and don't just
listen to what anybody's just telling
you do your own research and and
be your own your own nutritionist and be
your own scientist because
like
every time you eating is one of the
things that you do most times a day most
people eat three times a day what else
are you doing three times a day
nothing people don't shower three times
a day you know none of that stuff so
it's like
at least be aware of what it is that
you're doing the most time in most of
your life
you know don't just allow don't just let
it be anything that you're putting in
down your mouth or feeding to your kids
or feeding to your pregnant wife
whatever yeah educate yourself like
invest yourself in what that's all about
and connect yourself more closely to the
food choices that you're making for
yourself and for your kids i mean
you know i think for you
uh the most powerful thing that you can
do and the most powerful way for you to
carry the message
is just to keep getting stronger and and
and play your ass off on the field you
know what i mean because especially for
dudes it's like it's what you do
you know is going to trump whatever's
coming out of your mouth it's almost
like if you do that it doesn't matter
what you're saying you you don't have to
say anything yeah you know because
everyone gets it
yeah you know so i want to see you
kicking some ass thanks man i'm going to
yeah yeah yeah
well i think that's a beautiful way to
to wrap it up and close it down but but
i think you know one thing i'd like to
leave people with
is
you know maybe some
some tips or or some inspiration for
somebody who's listening to this
and
they're new to these ideas you know and
and they're interested they're intrigued
they're like wow i never would have
thought like a dude in the nfl like
really and so maybe they're ready to you
know kind of dip their toe in the water
like where
where where would you or where do you
suggest you know people make that first
step how do you do that
well
i mean you're you're an all-in dude like
i kind of was a little bit too you know
what i mean like yeah i started you
flick that switch and it's over with but
most people aren't like that yeah i
started like like you said all in the
next day but uh
it's hard for a lot of people to to go
vegan because first they don't even know
where to begin
and um
you know
you know the best way to do is to look
up some look and start researching and
look up some you don't really have to
look far look look on the internet and
look up some recipes
and find some creative recipes something
easy something simple that you can
that you can make really quickly and you
know it's not a huge hassle and
you know that's what i'm doing right now
i'm working with this company
it's called it's called lighter
and we're and we're creating it's
lighter and it's a it's a group
the nutritionist is actually a runner
a marathon runner and she's uh
we're working together to
create heavier which is which is my half
of lighter
but
it's pretty cool right
so oh no it's not heavier it's stronger
that was the first name stronger but
it's heavier that's kind of a negative
most people don't want to get they don't
want heavier i know it's stronger
but um it's an awesome it's an awesome
concept it's really like you know it's a
personal nutritionist
and they do all the shopping for you
basically and bring it to your front
door it's like an app is what you're
talking about it's a website and it's
called uh lighter
and
lighterculture.com lighterculture.com
and yeah it's pretty awesome man great
stuff and they do the best job to get as
close to non-gmo as possible they follow
the the the big is it called the big
nines they're dirty dozens of dirty
dozens they're dirty dozens and um
it's it's awesome awesome they do they
get great products and all that stuff
and they have recipes and a lot of my
recipes are up there and what i do to my
weight gaining recipes and what i do for
pre-workout after workout and all that
stuff so
it's awesome but um that's one option
but then you know uh going on going
online and looking up uh there's another
great website it's uh oshiegloves.com
they have great recipes that's one of
the websites that got me started and
it's it's very easy yeah yeah she's
awesome
but um yeah there's it is plenty of
vegan options like i said i'm not a big
fan of the processed foods but there's
huge process there's there's there's um
gardein and and uh
beyond meat is awesome they have great
great food beyond that it's just a smell
i love this mayo yeah i mean so
for somebody who's not ready to let go
of of those like for you and me it's
like i don't it's not about that stuff
anymore but like most people like they
just you know they need to transition so
yeah those foods have their place for
that but i think i think people
over complicate it in their mind because
they don't they don't know right so they
think it's going to be hard or
cardboard all these foods yeah or all
this meal prep they're gonna have to you
know spend all day because spent all day
in the kitchen creating these recipes
because the idea is like oh you're
trying to recreate
uh something that tastes like meat and
dairy but it's not about that no no it's
so simple it's like look we're sitting
here we're eating we're eating a bowl of
blueberries yeah did we have to prepare
that no it's already made i got a big
bag of almonds over there and some
bananas
and a big bag of rice and a big bag of
beans and like if all you did was go to
the store and buy a bag of rice and
beans
you're good that's a meal that's huge
that's that's a huge start yeah make a
big thing of rice and a big thing of
beans and put it in your refrigerator
and then you can eat for a week yeah
just add some some simple things avocado
tomato and you're good and that's a
that's a full-on delicious meal right
there i love it that's my one of my
favorites but
yeah a lot of people make it a lot
harder
than what it is and like we said earlier
that's probably the meat on companies
uh adding all these extras to it and
hyping it making it something that is
not but it's very easy and it's very
inexpensive
yeah yeah and
i mean it's it's not just the meat
companies it's it's cultural you know
this is there's just this hardened idea
that this is what it is and so you know
it's people like you that are that are
you know changing that perspective so
uh thank you for that man thank you bro
appreciate it you're an inspiration i
can't wait for you to get that phone
call i want to see what you're going to
be doing next year and i'm excited for
you man thank you bro and i want to come
down and visit you guys in costa rica oh
you should you're supposed to and then
we end up coming down here so i know
like we got to make that happen somehow
i'd love to do that
my friend charlie knowles is going to be
moving down there soon he's a meditation
teacher i should connect you to him too
oh nice i don't know what part of costa
rica it is but
probably where we are that's like the
big hippie zone where we're living oh it
is i thought the whole country was a big
hippie zone and ours is like the
concentration of hippies where we are
right there isn't there all right man
yeah i like it thanks a hippie in the
nfl
got to do it man
all right man well uh thanks for
dropping by all the kind of books and
references that we made throughout this
conversation will be in the show notes
uh
on the episode page at ritual.com for
this episode so go there and check that
out and
dig in and uh you know pull that thread
and go on your own journey with all this
stuff man right all right cool i think
we did it yeah how do you feel feel good
that was good man you know hey this is a
good interview you have to have me back
on one second time anytime man anytime i
would love to have you back on i'd love
to have you back on uh after you know
you're back and playing and come and
share you know what that's all about and
what that what's that like all right you
do that no problem man cool man all
right peace peace flats
[Music]
you